[музика]
мова українська гордосте моя кришталево
чисте в лузі джерело ти- свята молитва
пісня Солов'я маминого серця ласка і
тепло Добрий день дорогі друзі у цей
святковий час Щиро вітаємо вас
поціновувачів української мови та
прихильників міжнародного конкурсу з
української мови імені Петра Яцика
цьогоріч конкурс вкотре об'єднає тисячі
знавців української мови від
школярів-третьокласників до студентів
вищив і сьогоднішній день стане початком
Чесного відкритого змагання талантів
знань і любові до рідної мови Щиро
вітаємо всіх з нагоди відкриття 24го
міжнародного конкурсу імені Петра
[музика]
Яцика
України і
[музика]
славаніляно бра
українці
усміхнеться
тоя
згинуть наші
[музика]
горіженьки я
роса на
соці запанує
[музика]
диви
браття у свої іськороти
[музика]
душй тіло ми
полоди про нашу
свобору і
покаже щоми
браття
постаського
роду во
діло ми
положи до нашу
сду і
покажем що ми
братя козакого
[музика]
ро Слава Україні героям Слава до
вітального слова Запрошуємо заступника
міністра освіти і науки України Андрія
сташківа Добрий день дорогі учасники
конкурсу учні учениці студентки та
студенти педагоги радий вас вітати з
Міжнародним конкурсом з української мови
імені Петра Яцика щорічно цей конкурс
об'єднує навколо себе дуже багато
учасників Минулого року їх було понад
800 і надзвичайно приємно що в ньому
беруть участь е учасники з інших країн
адже це показує наскільки їм важливо
зберігати зв'язок з Україною свою
ідентичність е з українською культурою
та належність до української нації ми
проводили цей конкурс в час ковіду коли
все можна було робити тільки дистанційно
і Ми продовжуємо його проводити в час
війни коли зстикнулися з повномасштабним
російським вторгненням
адже наскільки це важливо показує те що
Росія хоче не просто знищити українців
але хоче знищити нашу культуру та
ідентичність тому знання української
мови е вміння володіти нею є надзвичайно
важливим Я запрошую всіх долучатися до
цього конкурсу та активно подавати свої
заявки на участь в ньому Бажаю всім
успіхів та Перемоги Слава Україні
останніми роками наша країна зіткнулася
зі страшними загрозами Спочатку це був
ковід тепер повномасштабна агресія
Російської Федерації проти України проте
конкурс не зупинився він змінився
перейшов у дистанційний формат завдяки
цьому тисячі українських учнів та
студентів яких війна змусила покинути
рідні домівки приєдналися до конкурсу
українського слова і підтвердили свою
українську ідентичність про українську
мову зброю говоритиме Павло Гриценко
голова журі конкурсу директор інституту
української мови Національної академії
наук України шановні
друзі конкурс
знавців української мови імені Петра
Яцика
це прекрасна українська
традиція яка
показує усім у світі Ми
українці ставимося до своєї
мовивайливо уважно вивчаємо її
поширюємо дбаємо за її красу силу
і весь час
демонструю дуже важливе положення Мова -
це та небачена сила яка об'єднує усіх
нас Мова - це те що нас вивищує дає нам
крила дає нам подих
інший коли ми говоримо рідною мовою
Ми влітаємо в піднебесі колись Шевченко
написав Ну що б здавалося
слова Слова та голос більш
нічого а
ер б'є ожива Як їх почує
знать от Бога і голос
і ті
слова ось з таким ставленням до мови як
до
найвищого
дару
долі ми підходимо у щоденному
мовокористуванні тому то ми з вами
вижємо про поширення
української
Дбаємо про те
аби
залишки тоталітаризму
русифікації нашого мовомислення і
мовокористування відійшли зовсім у
минуле танули як кажуть у
ле Мова
це та сила яка об'єднує від
учнів до воїнів і генералів тому що Мова
- це
осерддя Нації Це хребет
нації і коли Діти вивчають мову вони
долучаютьже до цього процесу до
процесу утвердження
українськості до процесу
зміцнення України як держави а воїни
наші батьки цих дітей дідусі цих дітей
там на фронті сьогодні боронять кожен
сантиметр кожну п'ять нашої землі Ось
так ми об'єднані і об'єднує воєдино нас
та
мова дорогі мої
причетність
домови це велике
святодійство причетність до мови це
можливість Увійти у широкі
інтелектуальні
емоційні культурні простори які
виформувані традиціями нашого народу які
виформувані інтелектом нашого народу
упродовж століть невипадково ворог
прийшовши на нашу землю ставить за мету
знищити нашу мову тому що він
знає є мова є народ є
держава і доти доки ми будемо з вами
говорити українською мовою співати
українських пісень мислити категоріями
українськості єдиної України
ми
непереможні з українською мовою
із
вірою в українське і
начало України і продовження і
утверження
української України
українськомовного простору ми з вами
непереможні і
обов'язково
і мога Буде за нами Слава
Україні в учасників минулорічного
міжнародного конкурсу з української мови
імені Петра Яцика запитали про мотиви
їхньої участі в конкурсі послухайте
деякі
відповіді для мене конкурс - це
скарбниця знань яка щоразу поповнюється
Артем
Солдатенко Я прагну покращити свої мовні
навички та поглибити знання з українсько
мови Марія
шликова Назар дорма хотів спробувати
свої сили щоб перевірити знання та
позмагатися за перемогу з найкращими
знавцями української
мови в Україні зараз важкі часи але наша
мова гордо звучить усьому світі Я
пишаюся тим що бере участь у конкурсі
саме в цей час вважає Марія аврошко
участь у конкурсі мій внесок у велику
перемогу наш держави бо українське слово
сьогодні теж зброя сильного нескореного
і непереможного народу Анна
проботюк своєю мотивацією та своїм
досвідом Перемоги в конкурсі поділиться
Володимира Гавриш переможеться 22 та
23го міжнародного конкурсу з української
мови імені Петра Яцика стипедіатка
президента України учениця Ніжинського
ліцею Ніжинського державного
університету імені Миколи Гоголя Мова -
це те що тече по кожній частинці нашого
тіла те що закладалося впродовж віків це
сили старанність фантазія предків кров
героїв які доблесно боронять її від
загарбників Мова - це код ідентифікації
Скриня з написом скарб котра захована
глибоко в душі держави ціною те що наші
мовознавці започаткували конкурси
ушанумитцям які зробили неймовірно
вагомою вкладвиток українського мовлення
конкурс імені пера Яцика - це можливість
продемонструвати свої знання здібності
висловити думку пофантазувати помріяти
Та самоствердитися це розвиває наше
мислення і є дуже цікавим та корисним
переможці 23го конкурсу імені Петра
ясика які отримують стипендію президента
України вирішили зробити благодійний
внесок у громадську організацію
однодумців і меценатв які об'єдналися з
метою допомогти дітям України
організацію Джен Ra адже усвідомлюємо що
в єдності та взаємопідтримці наша сила
тож конкурс і Петра Яцика об'єднує серця
[музика]
[оплески]
українців
[музика]
Привіт тобі друже вітаю Т брате по
тільки ратом нам недолю здолати
прокомкуртувати вклекати країну Соборну
помісну свою Україну тарці немає такого
куточку де б краще ти виховав сина та
дочку моря і гориі отера відчується
душею розлися весело культура історія
мова іні це все приковано в твоїй
батьківщині Можливо ще поки не все про
ти знаєш та найголовніше що прагнеш
бажаєш будь з нами будь українцем РАІ що
тут народиться якщо ти Деш тим за мною
себе відчує собою сть з нами муд
українцем краї що тут народився Іна
свята і до зброї підемо разом з тобою
[музика]
[оплески]
впевнені сильні вимужні порзі вибір бе
вибору нам непричасних рітній спіноті
своє здобувати від серця до серця ї Хато
до хати а до побратима протягнемо руку
іким Ще сильніше іптвердимо хку великої
нації Прагу народу апуємо водами Сяну за
зду А ти перемогам народу радієш про Вла
внесох у них завжди вріж працюй над
собою люби дане богам Бо твій власний
приклад і є допомога устами буть
українцем раді що тут народився якщо ві
не с за мною тебе І чує з тобою будь з
нами будь українцем радій що тут
народився і нас скадай до зброї демо
разом з
тобою Слава Україні Героям слава Україна
го все Україна голе з усе будь з нами
будь
українцем
[музика]
будь з нами будь українцем ді Що тут
народився Якщо підеш світ за мною себе
відчуєш з тобою будь з нами будь
українцем таій що тут народився і на
свята і до зброї Ідемо разом з тобою
будь з нами будь українцем краї що тут
народивться якщо ти йдеш Рім за мною
тебе відчує з тобою будь з нами будь
українцем краій що тут народився і на
свята і до зброї Ідемо разом з
[музика]
тобою
будь з нами будь
[оплески]
українцем пісню будь з нами будь
українцем нам подарували її автор Максим
трубніков та учні Одеського ліцею номер
де щоб проникнути в таку тонку і
неосяжну величну і багатогранну річ як
мова Треба її любити слова Василя
Сухомлинського нині влучно передають
світлі почуття всіх учасників 24го
міжнародного конкурсу з української мови
імені Петра Яцика його меценатів та
організаторів від імені організаторів
конкурсу до вас звертається виконавчий
директор Міжнародного благодійного фонду
ліга українських меценатів Світлана
короненко
слабошпицька
дорогі друзі конкурсанти вчителі батьки
Сьогодні ми маємо справжнє свято
розпочинаємо черговий 24й міжнародний
конкурс з української мови імені Петра
Яцика починаємо його на славній
Миколаївській
землі цей черговий мовний марафон знову
проходитиме в умовах
російсько-української війни проходитиме
не просто а але сьогодні Кожен з нас
знає українська мова - це не просто
слова якими ми говоримо в нашій
державі не просто державна мова сьогодні
це насперед наша
зброя така самозброя якою була впродовж
століть нашу мову забороняли і цих
заборон нараховують понад
150 наші палили українців знищували Але
кожного разу усупереч нашим ворогам наша
українська мова наче Фенікс
відроджувалася знову і знову наш конкурс
цьогоріч відбудеться в 24й раз
переконана що і цього разу наші
конкурсанти будуть активними і
продемонструють чудові знання рідної
мови а отже і любов до неї А навесні ми
привітає
найкращих з найкращих знавців
української мови за цієї нагоди хочу
також переказати сердечні вітання від
президента Ліги українських меценатів
Володимира Антоновича загорія а також
від членів Ліги українських
меценатів також вас вітає і Союз
українок Австралії який є меценатом
нашого конкурсу від самого його
початку Слава Україні
Слава українській
мові пані Світлана зазначила що
Відкриття цьогорічного конкурсу знавців
української мови відбувається в
Миколаєві у незламному нескороному місті
герої на славетній землі
миколаївщина мальовнича Перлина
півдня батьківщина старанних розумних
талановитих
людей дім сміливих та
незламних
щодня область піддається обстрілам
країниагресора Але незважаючи ні на що
миколаївщина продовжує
жити
любити творити і найголовніше вчитися
занурюючись у минуле розвитку
української мови вибудовуємо майбутнє
України пам'ятаймо Про це
допоки є мова існує держава пам'ятаємо
це миколаївщина як і всі регіони України
схвалила програму розвитку української
мови виконаємо її разом освітяни
державні службовці працівники культури
театрів бібліотек мешканці миколаївщини
говорять
українською Говоримо
українською
міжнародний конкурс з української мови
імені Петра Яцика стартує в День
української писемності та мови що
розпочався всеукраїнським радіодиктантом
національної єдності із цим подвійним
святом вас вітає у повноважений із
захисту державної мови Тарас Кремінь
шановні друзі як уповноважений захисту
державної мови я вас Щиро вітаю з
початком 24го міжнародного конкурсу з
української мови імені Петра Яцика цей
конкурс вкотре довів що він є одним з
найголовніших у системі нашої
гуманітарної підготовки нашої оборони
ключовим у питаннях національної безпеки
і оборони тому що захищати українську
мову розвивати її утверджувати і стояти
на дорозі її популяризації це значить
зміцнювати наш мовний фронт я радо Вітаю
вас І з тим що ми справді зміцнюємося і
переходимо у своєрідний мовний
Контрнаступ буквально Минулого року ми з
вами розмірковували про долю країни про
волонтерство обговорювали питання
пов'язані із містами героями України Я
уродженець Миколаєва і мені радісно що
моє місто герой витримало так само як і
витримав Харків так само як і витримали
Одеса Київ Буча Ірпінь гостоміль
водночас це і міста страдники які
пережили величезні втрати ракетні
обстріли велика кількість людей
опинилися за межами своїх улюблених
містечок сіл і селищ дехто перебуває за
кордоном але всі ми об'єднані спільною
метою єднатися боротися і перемагати
тому я сподіваюся що цьогорічний конкурс
об'єднає значно більшу кількість
учасників ми будемо мати достойних
переможців і вони будуть не тільки з
числа здобувачів загальної середньої
освіти але й фахової передвищої освіти
звичайно університетської молоді а також
всіх українців Хто зараз тимчасово
перебуває за кордоном давайте працювати
на утвердженні украї ї ідентичності
досліджувати незнані грані української
мови і української культури думати про
те в який спосіб зміцнити українську
мову як уповноважений Я недавно взяв
участь у міжнародній генеральній
асамблеї європейської Федерації
національних мовних інституцій весь світ
аплодує тому як ми боремося як ми
спілкуємося українською мовою і кожен
Іспанець португалець чи поляк Вони
знають точно що для нас означає
українська мова тому
працюємо вивчаємо долучаємося до цієї
великої роботи і перемагаємо я з вами до
перемоги Слава
Україні поки нею говорять наш конкурс
Житиме доти поки в ньому братиме участь
талановита молодь з усієї України Та
закордоння поки вчителінаставники
невтомною працею допомагатимуть своїм
вихованцям підтримуватимуть їхнє бажання
дізнаватися нове та демонструвати свої
досягнення від димені вчителів до вас
звертається переможець всеукраїнського
конкурсу учитель року
2022 лідер рок-гурту друже музико
учитель Одеського ліцею номер 9 Максим
трубніков Вітаю вас шановні учасники
міжнародного конкурсу з української мови
імені Петра Яцика ваша участь в конкурсі
має велике державотворче значення
українська мова пережила величезну
кількість заборон і зараз зі рою в руках
українську відстоюють наші войни А ті
хто говорять українською щодня
наближають нашу перемогу сподіваюсь і
інші народи світу проявляючи
Солідарність з Україною почнуть вивчати
мову
[музика]
героїв О рідне слово хто без тебе
я і миж брак старцюючи Бродяга
рлях поросли плиттям саркофага
рах купа
жалюгідного
рам'я моя ти пісня сила і
відвага моє вселюдськей мамине
ім'я тобою полохтить душа моя
ішається тобою в серці
спрага тебе УПА віддали
мені мої батьки і пребки
невідомі що кинули за тебе на
вогні тохто не засни в запиленому домі
нехнутій олінторові
Руні свини моїм і правнуковим
домі свини моїм і правнуковим
домі у виконанні пана Максима прозвучала
пісня О рідне слово на слова Дмитра
Павличка прозора й чиста як гірська вода
то України Мова
барвінкова така багата ій вічно молода
Вона Як ніжна пісня колескова відлунюєш
В мені крізь плин років моє прадавнє
материнське мово і полиновим присмаком
гірким і найсолодшим проявом медовим ти
заповітна на Хліб святий звучиш із літ
дитячих ще з колиски і та любов до тебе
надцвіти вона назавжди біля серця
близько Шановні учні та студенти
педагоги та батьки Дякуємо що долучилися
до нашого заходу Ще раз вітаємо зі
святом української писемності та мови
учіть рідну мову Плекайте її адже допоки
живе державна мова кот нашої нації доти
український народ лишає незламним і
незнищенним з вами були Віталій Гладун
та Анастасія Кузнецова працівники
Миколаївського обласного інституту після
дипломної педагогічної освіти до нових
зустрічей